on va vous faire une interview alors
j'explique bien le principe c'est une
nouvelle interview c'est l'interview
alain delon donc vous devez répondre à
la troisième personne
la bouche bien interview alain delon
donc première fois légaliser les drogues
douces vous trouvez ça stupéfiants vous
trouvez stupéfiants qu'on l'ait pas
encore fait
kamal trouve ça stupéfiants j'aime bien
falloir vous trouvé ça vraiment
stupéfiant qu'on a gagné jusqu'à mail
trouve sa stupéfiante
c'est bien à certains moments kamel
non mais ça pour surtout qu'il est trop
facile de se la péter donc quand même
trop ça stupéfiants de deux ça fait
quatre fois de ne pas légaliser les
drogues douces parce qu'il ya une drogue
qui est qui est légal et la cigarette
qui fait mal et plus de dégâts et ça
dérange personne puis à l'alcool puis
elle veut c'est qu'ils sont les premiers
consommateurs notamment de
tranquillisants
je crois donc que c'est loin d'être
kamel pense donc que c'est loin d'être
la drogue la plus la plus néfaste pour
pour l'individu en tout cas très bien
alors question sexe est ce que vous êtes
pour la réouverture des maisons closes
ou la fermeture des boîtes à partouzes
écouter kamel pense qu'ils se feraient
bien de
de réouvrir les maisons closes déjà pour
des raisons d'hygiène et de sécurité et
jeu camel peu trouve ça beaucoup plus
sain entre guillemets que les boîtes à
partout c'est ce qu'il pense bien
lux pour vous c'est du coca dans un
verre en cristal ou du petrus dans un
gobelet en plastique
carmen restera sur le caucase lui qui ne
boit pas d'alcool 1
donc ça sera un verre de coca dans un
verre de cristal dacca dalla betta
d'alcool par ses votes religion dit
musulman pratiquant croyants écoutez il
est né musulman
oui ça me fait drôle il est né il est né
musulman et il a fait beaucoup de sport
au début donc il ne buvait pas par la
part pour le chef il a fait d'une pierre
deux coups en fait d'accord très bien
alors pour faire du social
est ce que vous pensez qu'il faut
augmenter les salaires ou diminuer le
temps de travail
kamel pense que ça serait bien
d'augmenter les salaires et deux en même
temps diminuer le temps de travail que
je crois que l'on sait
est ce que j'avais le sentiment d'avoir
le plus souvent raté des trains votre
chance ou l'occasion de vous taire sans
hésiter kamel a le plus souvent été des
trains oui parce que tout le temps en
retard ils abominable
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'interview alain delon c'est très
simple nous souhaitons bel récupérables
et plusieurs portables ont sonné mais se
retrouver en panne il va récompenser
alors la table alain delon emmanuel
c'est très simple il suffit de répondre
à la troisième personne
légaliser les drogues douces vous
trouvez que c'est une idée stupéfiants
tous qu'il est stupéfiant que ça n'ait
pas encore été fait emmanuel pense que
ça soit stupéfiant que ce soit pas
encore fait car ça enlèverait quand même
beaucoup de criminalité de petite
criminalité et voilà encore une fois dès
qu'il ya un roi il veut légaliser la
marijuana c'est le cas en espagne c'est
le camp hollande vous ambiancer ça je
veux remettre la casquette du raid
parlant du commerce du sexe maintenant
est ce que vous êtes pour la réouverture
des maisons closes ou pour la fermeture
des boîtes à partouzes à emmanuel et
pour une prostitution contrôler ouais
tout comme la drogue
ouais et donc pour la réouverture des
maisons closes contrôler et de qualité
pour faire du social vous choisiriez
d'augmenter les salaires ou diminuer le
temps de travail
voilà je parle pour moi emmanuel parle
pour soit d'augmenter tout en diminuant
le temps de travail c'est difficile de
choisir
en france ils ont choisi les 35 heures
qu avez-vous le sentiment d'avoir le
plus raté votre chance d'être un ou d
occasion de vous taire
emmanuel pense que il a souvent raté
l'occasion de se taire
on ne bouge pas on allait génial
on ne bouge pas pendant le jingle
ah ça repose de belles filles alors
est-ce que légaliser les drogues douces
ça vous semble une idée stupéfiante où
il vous semble stupéfiants qu'on n'est
pas déjà fait alors là jean marie bigard
pense que
comme de toute façon tout le monde le
fait ouais ben ça changerait pas grand
chose en fait
et donc que tout le monde se bat
toujours pour la légalisation de
marijuana blanc fait c'est fait c'est ce
que vous de oui voilà à peu près à peu
près c'est ce que jean marie bigard
pense oui c'est ce pardon excusez moi
alors on va passer maintenant au
commerce du sexe qui est un sujet qui
est nouveau pour vous est ce que vous
êtes pour la réouverture des maisons
closes ou pour la fermeture des boîtes à
partouzes nom alors je suis alors alain
delon d'ailleurs démarqué par sa
pareille pareil que pour la première
question jean marie bigard et pour le
cul existe tout bon de le pratiquer
il ya des bordels absolument partout et
les quartiers entiers de paris où il est
possible évidemment de deux squats et ça
coûte des fois un petit peu cher mais on
boit un verre avec une jeune fille à
moitié dénudée jean marie bigard l'a
fait déjà et
jean marie vien s'est aperçu que
derrière le petit rideau la bouteille de
champagne passé de 1500 mal il fallait
et qu'il fallait enfin en fer en folie
en boire au moins 3 ou 4 avant de jean
marie billa pense que c'est cher est ce
que jean marie v garde pense que quand
on va dans un endroit comme ça et puis
qu'on est derrière le rideau avec la
jeune fille dénudée et qu'on a bu trois
bouteilles de champagne on peut encore
la sauter la fille
jean marie bigard pense que c'est c'est
emmerdant de se retrouver avec des
agriculteurs qui sont allés au salon wii
et puis
de trois quinquagénaires rouge aux
anciens de la cgt ils sont l'oeil
jean marie bigard s'est fait comme tout
le monde piégée ouais bien sûr parce que
jean marie bigard est arrivé à paris oui
jean marie bigard est passé devant ils
d'innombrables le bar avec des jeunes
filles avec la moitié des niches en a
l'air et puis jean marie bigard est
rentré il est rentré l'a dit est ce que
je peux boire un verre et immédiatement
plusieurs jeunes filles se sont
représentés à lui alors que jean marie
bigard n'était pas connue encore qu'il
n'était pas jean marie bigard qu'est ce
qu'on fait maintenant
donc jean marie bigard s'est fait baiser
la gueule comme tout le monde mais c'est
vrai que c'est un endroit existe et donc
sont ouverts ils sont ouverts oui hélas
il est en fête
ça pourrait coûter moins cher bien oui
si on sorgues
si on s'organisait un peu jean marie
bigard est un petit peu déstabilisés par
par vos questions à quelle santé alors
bon on va passer à des choses plus
simples jean marie bigard votre
conception du luxe est ce que vous
préférez boire du coca cola dans un
verre en cristal ou du petrus dans un
gobelet en plastique
jean marie bigard préfère le petrus quel
que soit le contenant je préfère boire
du petrus même dans un gobelet anglais
absolument d'accord
est ce que pour garder celle que vous
aimez vous êtes prêt à l'enfermer dans
un palais ou à la sortir dans des clubs
échangistes a donc on retourne dans le
club ait changé que ça mais c'est
jean-marie s'il ya un petit peu non jean
marie bigard pense que l'enfermer dans
un palais évidemment c'est une solution
qui est très facile mais comme jean
marie bigard est un combattant jean
marie bigard peut éventuellement penser
qu à bout de souffle et s'il emmenait sa
femme d'un club échangiste je pense que
jamais à vegas sera un peu gêné de voir
peut-être sa femme se faire pénétrer par
le rouge au de la cgt tout à l'heure
donc
jean marie bigard ça rappelle cette
blague et jean marie bigard gafsa et qui
dit à son pote ça te dirait de venir
dans une partouze dit ouais et duo
serait combien m'a dit si tu viens avec
ta femme on sera trois bien qu'elle se
montrer plus choquant l'interdiction des
mariages homos ou la banalisation des
divorces hétéro oh la la
jean marie bigard est très choquée par
cette question c'est une originalité
encore une fois l'homosexualité c'est
bien qu'elle soit original donc il faut
pas la mettre dans un concept normal je
me lance et puis de north banalisée
banaliser les divorces hétéros les
divorces et héros bat jean marie bigard
pense que c'est déjà fait on a déjà pas
mal d'analysés mais jamais un bigard
rossy pense encore une fois que on se
donne une bonne conscience en déchirant
fait un papier avec quelqu'un mais je
pense que le désengagement qu'on a avec
une personne au delà de déchirer un
papier qui est un contrat de mariage ils
pensent que ce n'est pas une chose très
très jolie de toute façon et jean marie
bigard pense que
c'est mieux de rester sur ses positions
et jean marie bigard ne divorce pas
voilà j'aime rivière par exemple le
divorce par exemple par exemple avant
pour faire du social est ce que vous
augmentez les salaires ou vous
diminuerez le temps de travail
alors là jean marie bigard voudrait dire
un message à l'ensemble de la planète
c'est que le travail en aura pas de plus
en plus y en a de moins en moins airs de
moins en moins de travail donc il faut
se faire à l'idée qu'on travaillera de
moins en moins et donc il veut oui mais
il faut se faire à l'idée qu'il y aura
une ce sera un luxe de travailler et de
dire on travaille pour l'ensemble de la
planète et toutes les grosses
entreprises qui travaillent avec des
machines qui ne sont pas syndiqués à la
cgt qu'il n'hésite pas de banderole le
matin non mais on appuie sur un bouton
elles font de travail de dix personnes
dont il y aura toujours de moins en
moins de travail les grosses entreprises
vont gagner de plus en plus d'argent et
donc il va falloir à un moment que nous
on s'occupe autrement que par le travail
peut être en s'occupant se sont faire
peut-être s'occupant de son prochain
peut-être que on se spiritual ''sera
puisque c'est ce qui a été prédit par
tout le monde depuis des centaines
d'années
c'est qu'on me plaisanter avec ça se
présente pas
[Musique]
qui n'a jamais entendu 400 personnes
dans un achat chanter le home qui est le
siège de la bad et le son de l'univers
et c'est magnifique c'est le seul son
qui qui devrait entendre à chaque fois
qu'on a un peu de repos et on peut leur
faire pendant l'émission concept tourne
vers son soient intérieurs et je propose
qu'on fasse mon émission comme ça
certains nombres de pose absolument un
supposé me faire penser en régime c'est
pas trop mon truc dont je fais partie
des gars n'aiment pas quand vous vous
foutez de la gueule
line ensemble du village
bien alors jean marie un regard qu
avez-vous le sentiment d'avoir le plus
souvent ratés dans votre vie votre
chance d'être un ou d occasion de la
fermer
jean marie bigard ne rate pas de chance
il ne rate pas de train non plus jean
marie bigard est à l'heure tout le temps
il ne rate pas le train le train attend
jean marie bigard et jean marie bigard
je m'habille en cours ce qui est de
fermer sa gueule et ce qu'il avait à
faire aurait eu des occasions de fermer
sa gueule mais il a pensé que ce serait
dommage pour l'ensemble des êtres
humains de la planète qui attendent
l'avis de jean marie bigard
[Musique]
on ne bouge pas légaliser les drogues
douces vous trouvé l'idée stupéfiante où
il est stupéfiant que ça n'ait pas
encore été fait alain delon parce que on
n'a pas besoin de 2012 sans sa présence
car sa présence est suffisamment
stupéfiante en elle-même on va passer au
commerce du sexe maintenant est ce que
vous êtes pour la réouverture des
maisons closes ou la fermeture des
boîtes à partouzes alain delon ne
mélange pas sont membres sacré avec le
nombre fait du commun des mortels donc
cette question ne le concerne pas
très bien merci à l'iphone selon les
répondants avec la bêta nous a laissé la
fête des mères mitterrand la fête de la
musique evous qu'elle fait
aimeriez vous laisser jean françois
derec n'a pas besoin de laisser fait
particulière la simple présence de
jean-françois dérec est une fête
permanente d'accord
pour taper la frime vous préférez faire
sans bornes en ferrari avec un boudin ou
du bord d'un tracteur avec un canon jean
françois jalkh ne frime pas un
la simple présence de jean-françois
dérec transforme les quarts les boudins
gros canons et les tracteurs en ferrari
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment
d'avoir le plus souvent raté votre
chance d'être un ou l'occasion d'un père
m jean-françois dérec m'a jamais rien
rater mon petit bonhomme peut être est
ce que vous trouvez plus choquant
l'interdiction des mariages homos ou la
banalisation des divorces hétéro
beaucoup de personnes souhaitent avoir
des rapports hétéro ou homo avec
jean-françois dérec mais ils n'ont
encore trouvé aucun être humain digne
deux sont nombreuses à gré donc il eu
pour l'instant une pratique l'amoled on
est beau
le moral revient le beau-fils relève la
tête
donc c'est l'interview alain delon donc
ça c'est vraiment ces dames lamentable
c'est évitable
c'est misérable alors oui le début de
chaque au début de chaque réponse oui
vous devez dire pierre arditi pense que
bien un oui d'accord bakassi je
comprends alors légaliser les drogues
douces vous trouvé l'idée stupéfiante où
vous trouvez stupéfiants qu'on n'est pas
encore fait
il y avait invités il pense que c'est
plutôt stupéfiants qu'on n'ait pas au
moins essayer de le faire
votre conception du luxe c'est boire du
coca dans un verre en cristal ou du
petrus dans un gobelet en plastique
ah bah alors écoutez ça va être ma main
non non non
bah pierre arditi pense que le luxe
suprême serait tout de même de boire du
petrus et pas dans un dans une coupe en
cristal mais dans un wagon dans lequel
on peut faire tourner ce vin pour en
sortir tous les arômes à ce que le
petrus et un van meerab voilà ce qu'il
pense pierre hardy
pour taper la frime vous préféré rouler
sans bornes en ferrari avec un boudin ou
dix bornes en tracteur avec un canon il
préfère rouler 10 bornes en tracteur
avec un canon mais qui gére arditi pour
vous le plus choquant c'est
l'interdiction des mariages homos ou la
banalisation de divorce et héros pour
pierre arditi c'est évidemment
l'interdiction des mariages homos qui
noyautent le plus bien entendu bien
voila voila pour faire du social
vous pensez qu'il faut augmenter les
salaires ou diminuer le temps de travail
via pierre arditi et très emmerder mais
il arriva il va répondre
il va répondre je ne peux pas répondre
aussi crûment jeu même pierre arditi
dans même pierre arditi n'est pas pierre
arditi pense qu' il n'est pas forcément
obligatoire de réduire le temps de
travail depuis lundi qui pense qu'il
serait bon d'augmenter certains salaires
parce que ça fait repartir l'économie
que ça permet aux gens de vivre moins
mal
il ya perazzi pense qu'il ya peut être
un moyen terme à trouver entre une durée
du temps de travail qui serait pas
codifié à coups de serpe vient la ville
ne pas pas codifié à coups de serpe et
le travail 7 aussi d'avis mais pierre
arditi pense qu'effectivement surtout
pour des gens qui gagnent peu leur vie
c'est qu'il voit assez souvent même au
cours de la sienne de vie de pierre
arditi pense quand même que il serait
mieux que les gens qui gagnent peu
d'argent en gagne un peu plus allemand
ferait pas de mal voilà ce que pense
pirates
les chats et les chiens ça tombe bien il
est chaud il adore dire son nom
jouissant oui bah oui c'est pour ça
qu'il est toujours à l'antenne alors on
va parler du commerce du sexe
êtes vous pour la réouverture des
maisons closes ou pour la fermeture des
boîtes à partouzes pierre arditi dira on
est dans la merde qui franchement la
pierre arditi les pour
au beaucoup je suis pour la jeune fille
pour la réouverture des boîtes et
partout n'importe quoi pardon maman dans
l'imaginaire qu'il faut s'excuser
inventeur il le fait tous les soirs dans
jésuites à qui donne le trouver pour
garder celle que vous aimez
est-ce que vous préféreriez l'enfermer
dans un palais où là sortiront les clubs
échangistes je serais capable de faire
le pire a dit qu'ils seraient capables
de faire les deux pour garder celle
qu'il aime parce qu'il a vraiment aucune
envie de la perdre et donc il pourrait
l'enfermer dans un palais si elle le
voulait bien où la trimballer dans un
club échangiste si c'était le seul moyen
de la garder pour le club échangiste ils
le feraient s'ils n'y avait pas d'autre
moyen seulement tu vois il est d'accord
evelyne chéri
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
légaliser les drogues douces vous trouvé
l'idée stupéfiante où vous trouvez
stupéfiant que c'est pas encore été fait
ils pensent que
enfin yvan attal pense que ce serait
bien maintenant de légaliser une bonne
fois pour toutes
votre conception du luxe c'est boire du
coca cola dans un verre en cristal ou du
petrus dans un gobelet en plastique
quitte à se la péter vraiment yvan attal
yvan attal est même beaucoup le petrus
même dans un gobelet prestige en
plastique on s'y fait finalement radio
ça c'est une façon de battre et je sais
pas je me suis redressait ils vont s est
redressée il a inhalé ce soir ils vont
faire illusion mais on lui a apporté un
petit accoudoirs avez vous le sentiment
d'avoir le plus souvent raté votre
chance d'être un ou d occasion de vous
taire
ils vont être un peu vous demander de
avez vous le sentiment d'avoir le plus
souvent raté votre chance d'être un ou d
occasion de vous taire exclusive en
interne est trop con bon compte
quand il dort il aura décidé de le voilà
alors il vous demande de passer à la
question suivante ça va je ne veux pas
répondre devant elle ne veut pas rester
survivants at elle pense qu'il a laissé
passer quelques chances mais bon c'est
on va pas se rendre sur ce sujet pour
vous le plus choquant c'est
l'interdiction des mariages homos ou la
banalisation des divorces hétéro ils
vont à ta leçon s'en fout un peu aussi
la différence car elle sait qu'alain
delon il a un avis sur tous les points
la différence hockey dernière il va
venir je vais tenir à la whey venir me
mettre un pas question question commerce
du sexe êtes vous ils vont à table pour
la turquie balcon êtes vous pour la
réouverture des maisons closes ou la
fermeture des boîtes à partouzes yvan
attal et pour la réouverture des maisons
closes et aussi et pas du tout cas pas
pour la fermeture des voies très bien ce
livre à 15 ans il va bien
[Applaudissements]
m
à part les dix mois le dow
légaliser les drogues douces oubli des
stupéfiantes où elle trouve stupéfiant
que cela n'ait pas encore été fait
muriel de longs voyages de l'ong pense
que c'est stupéfiant d'être stupéfait
[Applaudissements]
c'est la conception du luxe c'est comme
un plombier jeudi lille où elle sait
comment elle va se battre ouais ça va
oui mais là je peux pas vous le savez
comment ça va mais là je n'ai pas voulu
mettre cette semaine ça pour faire du
social
elle augmenterait les salaires ou elle
réduit le temps de travail alors muriel
robin c'est donc c'est très dur tu vas
muriel robin
qu'est ce qu'elle en trois mois alors
quand le temps le travail social
la très chaud puisqu'elle dit content
d'être là alors pour taper la femmelle
préféré rouler sans bornes en ferrari
avec un boudin ou du bord en tracteur
avec un top canon muriel robin préféré
rouler dans une ferrari avec un top
canon les mélanges à l'aider mais je
veux pas voulu l'autre ça ne va pas du
tout en tant que star ce qu'elle
supporte le moins six être l'objet de
toutes les conversations ou être l'objet
d'aucune barbade
supporte pas de ne pas être un sujet de
conversation et c'est ok évidemment je
sais pas je n'ose même pas l'imaginer
elle commence à bien entrer dans le
comprendre mais ça peut lancer jouais
déjà d'arrêter de faire des télécoms ça
donc je pose la lune avant que c'est
plus lent que ce qu'elle a katell le
sentiment d'avoir le plus souvent raté
sa chance d'être un ou d occasion de la
fermer
je crois que comme muriel lou romain
louvre ça c'est toujours pour quelque
chose qu'on va bien votre question venir
rebelles de rats diamètre a campé à fait
ce qu'il faut c'est du fun parce que les
montées sur balles alors après faut
calmer le jeu prend pas ce commerce du
sexe est ce qu'elle est pour la
réouverture des maisons closes ou pour
la fermeture des boîtes à partys non
vraiment bien pense que les boîte à
partouze
c'est très agréable à vivre ici c'est
très drôle il adore dire des mots que je
dis pas souvent papa tandis que soit son
nom pense que la femme n'ont que les
boîte à partouze je me souviens déjà
plus là qu est ce qu il faut en tout cas
la leçon ouvertes et les maisons closes
aussi d'accord faut tout ouvrir mais
alors ma pense qu'il faut ouvrir le
merlan bas est elle même très ouvert
ça vient
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes prêts il est prêt ouais
votre conception du luxe et boire du
coca dans un verre en cristal ou boire
du petrus dans un gobelet en plastique
enfin il pense que c'est boire du et
russes dans un verre en cristal
ouais bien peu quand même pour faire du
social vous augmentez briller des
salaires ou vous diminuerez le temps de
travail
il est très peu concernés par la
question
il dira qu' il va augmenter les salaires
mais il ya ces démagogues assez une
période électorale
ouais il a besoin de se faire mais voilà
il a besoin de se faire aimer par là
j'aurais été donc il va dire il augmente
les salaires ils diminuent tous les
impôts il offre une maison mobalpa ou
maison témoin dôme expo à qui veux pas
qu'ils votent pour lui
pour taper affrime vous préféré rouler
sans bornes en ferrari avec un boudin ou
dix bornes en tracteur avec un top canon
étant donné qu'il vient de la sarthe
il va répondre qui va préférer être avec
un super beau tracteur qui déglingue
genre à massey ferguson qui est aussi
bon qu'une ferrari est plus chère avec
un canon énorme kommissar tout ça sans
doute oui ce boudin pour vous le
planchot se tient à préciser que ça vous
super cher un tracteur c'est du luxe a
oui je sais pas j'habite encore des
beaux arts j'entends des mots là bas
continue et il vous en prie il vous
écoute avec un plaisir non dissimulé
pour vous le plus choquant c'est
l'interdiction des mariages homos ou la
banalisation des divorces hétéro
il a il a envie de répondre autre chose
il envie de répondre que il comprend
toujours pas comment ça se fait qu'avec
la télé soit toujours pas mariée encore
ouais donc
il va répondre un truc complètement à
côté quoi s'est il est très jaloux des
deux noms quoi qu'il arrive parce que
lui il est toujours pas concernés par ce
genre de dilemme selon lui beaucoup
voilà de longs gants même chose pour
garder celle que vous aimez vous
préféreriez l'enfermer dans un palais où
la sortir avec les échangistes
ils préféreraient les deux il ferait
tout ouais ouais il sortirait la
surmultipliée et si vraiment il n'ya pas
le choix il n'en fermerai dans un palais
parce qu'il n'a pas trop confiance en
lui
que pensez-vous de franck dubosc l'homme
je ne connais pas franck dubosc fung
duboscq ne se confie pas énormément
fonds qui voit ce qui est très discret
vente au mans il se confie à sa
quéquette le soir dans la déprime
mais je ne fréquente pas énormément font
que du bosc pour vous franck dubosc est
synonyme de quoi au fond du bois ce
n'est pas un synonyme franck dubosc est
haï tu es bon tu vois ce qui est nul en
orthographe bien évidemment ce que vous
pensez que font du buzz aujourd'hui
devenu un grand comédien franck dubosc
n'est pas un grand comédien
la comédie est un grand guilbault ce cas
est-ce que vous pensez que franck dubosc
peut tout jouer notamment des merdes
[Rires]
alors franck dubosc ne joue pas dans des
mers de franck dubosc est de la merde et
je peux vous dire que beaucoup de gens
lui ont marché dessus
est-ce que vous pensez que franck dubosc
laissera une trace d'un cinéma français
vient de le dire est ce que franck du
buzz aujourd'hui atteint une certaine
sérénité
l'enfant qui voient ce n'est pas serein
un bon buzz peut éventuellement être
pigeons je sais bien qu'on croise quand
même les jeux de mots foireux
est-ce que vous pensez que franck dubosc
va se mettre à la chanson
car franck dubosc est bon en tout gai
record j'avais 20 ans je cache mon cul
parce qu'ils adresseront bon alors là
expert alors bientôt une vue à son nom
oui je vois ce qu'ils aimeraient avoir
une place non non une petite petite
impasse en nickel les amoureux pourrait
marcher
l'un et l'autre s'embrasser sous
d'époque attention à bien sûr bien
évidemment à s'embrasser sous des portes
cochères avec une lune qui descendraient
pour les abris franck dubosc et poète ce
qui est une très belle plume
on dit que forme du boss serait beaucoup
vu en ce moment en compagnie de top
model
ils en pensent quoi franck dubosc france
que quand il est avec des top models ne
pense pas il s est ce que font du bosc
est fier d'avoir honoré toutes les
femmes qui se sont présentées à lui on y
bosse n'est jamais fiers ils ceux qui
encore énormément de travail à faire
franck dubosc plaisante
est-ce que duboscq est une star au japon
si le japon est un des pays du monde
franck dubosc est une star au japon
et j'y tiens
franck dubosc admire alain deneault à l
inverse est approuvé pour frédéric
beigbeder est synonyme de quoi alors ça
dépend dans quel pays en lituanie c'est
synonyme d'orgasme même et si vous
prenez si vous prenez l'ukraine la
biélorussie et le aussi le sud
la bulgarie alors là c'est synonyme de
dollars de dollars contre contre des
services c'est triste ce que vous pensez
que c'est un matelas mais on est en
train de tourner deux minutes en
français le plus vendu à l'étranger en a
marre là qu'est ce qu'elle a fait ce
qu'elle a fait j'ai rien fait pour
manger rien si tu veux pas te laisser
faire
tu as bien raison mais moi je
j'ai vu j'en suis bouche bée
je suis pas en train d'essayer non plus
il faut pas arrêter de croire que je
suis beau zac saint brice houssou silva
studio brûla qui sauverait laquelle
question je cours plus vite sans lui
[Applaudissements]
est ce que vous pensez qu'on avait rêvé
d'être un grand écrivain frédéric
beigbeder en est persuadé mais oscar
dufresne n'est pas d'accord est ce que
frédéric beigbeder atteint aujourd'hui
une certaine sérénité
frédéric beigbeder cherche la sagesse il
essaie d'être honnête
ouais c'est déjà un début bien sûr la
sérénité à mon avis n'est il la trouvera
jamais jamais non jamais jamais jamais
jamais ça dans le coma voilà voilà
d'accord est ce que c'est vrai on dit
que frédéric beigbeder ces derniers
temps aurait passé beaucoup de temps
avec des top modèles dans des boîtes
topless et alors on alors on raconte
frédéric beigbeder à ce genre de vie
c'est très exagéré très exagérées
les photographies qui circule en ce
moment sur le net sont de grossier
photomontage d'accord voilà est-ce que
vous pensez il faudrait que dd doit
beaucoup à son physique
non là et personne n'a remarqué mais
c'est moi qu'il est foutu un bateau
algérien de montrer ses matches et des
données c'était grand jeu pas si sûr je
l'aï aussi atteint un replay non est ce
que frédéric beigbeder en a pas marre
qu'on lui parle toujours de l'hyper
chaud sur canal et son menton mais en
fait on s'est bizarrement frédéric
beigbeder déplore qu'on ne parle pas
plus de ces deux désastres
frédéric beigbeder un rapport familiale
avec les frères bogdanoff frédéric
beigbeder vient c'est vrai d'une autre
planète
est-ce que vous pensez que ce soit avec
beigbeder laissera une trace dans la
littérature frédéric beigbeder parce que
j'adore mais ce que je prononce souvent
deux mots que j'aime bien qu'ils sont
frédéric beigbeder invoquée
dire comme non laisser une trace n'est
pas le but ultime d'un écrivain il est
de formuler des émotions de peut-être
immortaliser des instants éphémères mais
mais pas nécessairement de
s'immortaliser lui-même recul c'est beau
ça je crois pas que sur son album plus
avec des trucs pareil [ __ ] c'est
énorme
comment ça se fait attendez attendez il
est tôt est ce que frédéric beigbeder
pense que le monde littéraire a de la
chance que frédéric beigbeder de salut
oui chanson parce qu'il est doué pour
tous en fête
frédéric b d a fait une tentative jeté
là je je ne suis pas fou je ne sais pas
patrick bruel je reste dans toutes les
mémoires t'en souviens de ça je ne suis
pas patrick bruel
ouais non non non non non non
bizarrement personne ne s'en souvient
moi si j'étais le producteur de
l'émission
est ce que frédéric beigbeder est fier
de faire fantasmer 3 milliards de femmes
alors dit retenir de frédéric beigbeder
voudrait qu'on revienne sur cette
statistique est parce que
la planète dont quelque six milliards
d'habitants que marc était si je me
trompe mais il ya plus de femmes que
d'hommes
ouais donc c'est plutôt de trois
milliards et demi de femmes d'asthme sur
frédéric beigbeder est fière d'être une
star au japon
mais frédéric edde aimerait bien mais ce
n'est pas le cas en russie oui on se mit
en crédits en turquie en qui se tend en
allemagne mais alors pas du tout du tout
au japon c'est très très gésiers un gros
problème au japon
il faut absolument faire quelque chose
si on pouvait lancer un appel est-ce que
les v 5 diffuse l'émission et rouge
auront bien sûr voilà tu peux en parler
alain delon est ce que je suis traduit
au japon mais alors que c'est un bide
total
ah bon ah oui oui absolue tombe bien bas
devant japonais constatons humour au
japon en plus comme j'ai adoré le film
de sofia coppola j'adorerais aller dans
des zones et des soldats au japon est ce
que frédéric b qu'ils aient réduit pour
jouer le rôle de la vrille
t'as pas remarqué les normes feeling
cumul a bien commencé marché connaît la
suite
là là je peux vous dire nicolas le
jardinier va te rhabiller
est ce que françois cluzet est une star
au japon françois cluzet n'est pas une
star au japon
que pensez-vous de françois cluzet
l'homme françois cluzet l'homme est
quelqu'un de danse de complexes et de
tout à fait attachant qui méritent
d'être découverts plus que plus
largement
est-ce que vous pensez que françois
cluzet est un bon acteur françois cluzet
certainement un des meilleurs acteurs
qui est en france en ce moment le public
adore françois cluzet françois cluzet
n'est pas encore autant aimé qu'il le
sera bientôt
[Applaudissements]
est ce que françois cluzet a atteint
aujourd'hui une certaine sérénité
françois cluzet n'atteindra vraiment
jamais une sérénité ou alors c'est quand
il sera refroidi complète
non françois cluzet quelqu'un quand même
d'un relativement inquiet de
relativement énervé par les dirigeants
politiques relativement énervé par les
acteurs qui jouent cols des pyrénées
avait par l'humiliation que subissent
les noirs les gros les juifs et donc
vous avez pas encore très serein ne le
sent jamais je crois on dit que françois
cluzet devenu beau gosse il en pense
quoi françois cusey ya que françois
cluzet a quitté le bar est évidemment
quittant la bière a perdu quelques jours
voilà penser que françois cluzet doit
beaucoup à son physique
françois cluzet avait un physique qui
lui permettait de jouer tout c'est à
dire un physique médium voyez il peut
jouer en même temps les fils de bonne
famille en même temps les fils
d'ouvriers donc dans ce métier est une
bonne chose puisque vous êtes souvent
dans le casting de faim voilà est-ce que
vous pensez que françois qu'ils aient se
définit plus comme un acteur comme un
comédien a sûrement françois cluzet
comme un acteur je serai plus d'émotions
mais ce que j'ai beaucoup d'amis qui
sont comédiens mais moi j'ai pris le
parti d'essayer d'être spontané de
ramener le rôle à moi ce qui fait toute
la différence avec le théâtre avec le
personnage me suis pris les pieds sans
cesse dans ses histoires de personnages
un jour j'ai décidé d'arrêter de me
prendre les pieds dans le tapis et de
ramener le personnage à moi est ce que
vous pensez que françois cluzet
pas une trace dans le cinéma français je
pense qu'ils en laissera aucune
pourquoi parce que je pense que pour
laisser une trace il faut faire sa
promotion personnelle en permanence et
que finalement la trace ça a à voir avec
la postérité c'est à dire avec des
grands films et que je n'aurais pas fait
encore assez
donc vous pensez que françois cluzet
n'aura jamais une rue à son nom par
exemple à mémé de tout coeur j'espère
n'avoir j'avais énormément
est ce que françois cluzet est fier
d'avoir honoré toutes les femmes qui se
sont présentés à françois cluzet
on y est françois cluzet a eu beaucoup
de demande morose qui concerne l'
honneur aux femmes qui se sont
présentées à lui vous savez comme comme
un peu dans le film les suis intimidée
très longtemps les femmes n'aiment pas
les timides parce qu'elles sont élevées
aussi dans l'idée du prince charmant qui
doit faire le premier pas alors le
timide lui évidemment attend clairement
un effet c'est pas lui le timide c'est
pas très viril en fait pour les femmes
exactement c'est tout le problème est ce
que pour s'accuser aime bien parler
comme alain delon françois cluzet
déteste parler comme un ace que françois
cluzet mois bien que cette interview se
termine non françois cluzet préférerais
qu'elle continue
[Musique]
pensez vous que le public aime dany boon
dany boon pense que le public aime dany
boon mais mais mais pas autant que dany
boon ne s'aiment et dany boon et le jour
où le public chemra autant que dany boon
scène le public sera ce que c'est
qu'être dany boon pensez-vous de dany
boon l'homme dany boon pense que les
femmes ont beaucoup de chance que dany
boon soit un homme pour vous dany boon
est synonyme de quoi franchement je suis
dany boon est très déçue que thierry
ardisson pose cette question pensez vous
que dany boon soit le plus grands
comédiens français dany boon est un
grand comédien c'est vrai renesas pas
français il estimé ah oui pensez que
dany boon peut tout jouer
dany boon ne pourra jamais jouer dany
boon c'est beaucoup trop durs car il
faut être dany boon et en même temps
être dany boon et jouer dany boon c'est
impossible
dany boon est complètement défoncée
est-ce que vous pensez que dany boon
laissera une trace dans le cinéma
français une trace de pneu oui est ce
que dany boon espère avoir bientôt une
vue à son nom mais dany boon des attire
ardisson rentrer dany boon dans son gps
et tu verras est ce que dany boon est
lui aussi une star au japon
dany boon est elle effectivement était
au japon récemment avec un certain alain
delon et les japonais disait qui veut
dire qui est cet homme à côté de dany
boon et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de nos latitudes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible ou